And speaking of genetics, I love that you're doing genetic testing on people to really help match
them with nutrition counseling, essential oils, supplements, all these things. We recently
interviewed an epigenetic specialist here about that, that very topic. So I love that you're
integrating that. And it kind of sparked this question in me. I think that when we look at cancer
specifically and genetics, a lot of the assumption out there is that the cause of cancer is your genes.
Like it's just genetic, it's there. But from the research that I've seen on this topic,
really only about 5 to 10% of cancers are linked to gene defects. Is that the same studies that
you've seen? And I know you've done a lot of work on the causes of cancer. So I'd love to get into
that. I would agree. I think about 5% of cancers are caused genetically. But there's probably maybe
everybody with cancer has genetic pathways that would be beneficial to look at, to help.
So let me give you an example. So you could say that, okay, a BRCA gene defect, that's the gene.
That is the tumor suppressor gene for breast cancer and ovarian cancer. So let's take a step back
again. So a tumor suppressor gene are genes that we all have that kick on when a cell goes into
rapid replication. So if a cell goes into, so that's what cancer is, is the cell going into rapid
replication. That's an abnormal process, but it happens on a regular basis to all of us.
Cells, the replication process in the nucleus of the cell gets interrupted. And instead of that cell
replicating every 12 weeks in the mother cell died. That's called regeneration. That happens
constantly. Also, that's what healing is. The cell goes into replicating every day or multiple times
a day. That's what cancer is. If that happens, which it does, it should kick on our tumor suppressor
genes, which then kick on a pathway to stimulate apoptosis or cell death. So it's a protective measure
to keep us from getting cancer. So one could say that we all have cancer, which is true,
if we're just finding cancer with what it is. It's rapid replication of cells. So we all have rapid
cells in rapid replication. Then these tumor suppressor genes kick on and cause cell death and
kill the cell and protect us from ever having a diagnosis. People with defects on their tumor suppressor
genes, and we'll use the broker genes as an example, have an increased rate of cancer because
they're not kicking on that important pathway with horribly driven cancers like breast cancer.
So they have an increased risk of breast cancer because they have multiple defects in those
broker genes. So their risk goes up. So that's a small percentage of the population. And that's not
really what we're really concentrating on when we look at genes with a cancer patient. We look at
other risk factors like if like I described, let's say if I have a lot of defects on my
pond one pathway, that's a pathway that helps me detox large chemicals in my liver.
So if I have a lot of defects on that pond one pathway and I'm exposed to toxins in my food,
food coloring, the chemical herbicides and pesticides, I don't detox those as well as I could if I
didn't have those defects. So it doesn't mean I won't detox it, but I'm going to be a slower detoxer
of those things. So let's say you and I were living next to each other. We're both exposed to
the same toxic load, but I have a lot of defects on my pond pathway and you don't. You could clear
them out easier than the risk of ill health because of story toxins. It's going to be less for you
because you'll be story less on the risk of ill health, including cancer. For me, it's higher
because I'm not getting rid of those poisons. And if I don't get rid of poisons, they can't keep
circulating my blood. They'll kill me. My body stores them in the cells or in the extracellular
spaces. And then if they're stored in the cells, they could at some point down the road interrupt that
replication cycle. And it could cause rapid replication. And that's what you talk about a cause
of cancer as a pesticide or an herbicide or some chemical or a combination of the slurry of thousands
of different chemicals that I've been exposed to over the years. Then that that is the cause of
cancer for me. So looking at those detox pathways genetically could be extremely beneficial
prior to somebody getting cancer. It'd actually be a better idea, right? So boy, I have a lot of
pond pathway defects. Then you go, okay, what from the literature that's out there helps support
that pond pathway. And then what from a look at metabolic charts, what are the other cofactors that
help push that pond pathway? Would it be wise to supplement my diet or supplement with specific
nutrition to help support that pathway to help my slow detox of my pond pathway to be maybe a medium
detox of my pond pathway. I'm able to get rid of those things. And then lifestyle changes like wow,
because I have these pond pathway defects, I can even be more careful not to spray pesticides on my
in my house or spray herbicides on my lawn. Because now I can see the correlation my risk is higher
for all sorts of problems because of that.